what we're going to do in this video is
introduce ourselves to the quotient rule
and we're not going to prove it in this
video in a future video we can prove it
using the product rule and we'll see it
has some similarities to the product
rule but here we'll learn about what it
is and how how and where to actually
apply it
so for example if i have some function f
of x and it can be expressed as the
quotient of two expressions so let's say
u of x
over v of x
then the quotient rule tells us that f
prime of x
is going to be equal to and this is
going to look a little bit complicated
but once we apply it you'll hopefully
get a little bit more comfortable with
it it's going to be equal to the
derivative of the numerator function u
prime of x
times the denominator function v of x
minus
the numerator function
u of x
do that in that blue color
u
of x
times the derivative of the denominator
function times v prime of x and this
already looks very similar to the
product rule if this was u of x times v
of x then this is what we would get when
we took the derivative if this was a
plus sign but this is here a minus sign
but we're not done yet we would then
divide by
the denominator function squared
v
of
x squared
so let's actually apply this idea
so let's say that we have f of x
is equal to
x squared over cosine of x well what
could be our u of x and what could be
our v of x
well our u of x could be our x squared
so that is u of x and u
prime of x would be equal to 2x
and then this could be our v of x
so this is v of x
and v prime of x the derivative of
cosine of x with respect to x is equal
to negative sine
of x and then we just apply this so
based on that
f prime of x is going to be equal to the
derivative of the numerator function
that's 2x right over here that's that
there so it's going to be 2x times the
denominator function v of x is just
cosine of x
times cosine of x
minus
the numerator function which is just x
squared
x squared
times the derivative of the denominator
function the derivative of cosine of x
is negative sine x
so
negative
sine of x
all of that over
the denominator function squared so
that's cosine
of x and i'm going to square it i could
write it of course like this actually
let me write it like that just to make
it a little bit clearer and at this
point we just have to simplify
this is going to be equal to let's see
we're going to get 2x times cosine of x
2x
cosine of x negative times a negative is
a positive
plus
x squared
x squared times sine of x
sine
of x
all of that over
cosine
of x squared which i could write like
this as well and we're done you could
try to simplify it in fact there's no
not obvious ways to simplify this any
further
now what you'll see in the future you
might already know something called the
chain rule or you might learn in the
future but you could also do the
quotient rule using the product and the
chain rules which you might learn in the
future but if you don't know the chain
rule yet this is fairly useful